ANGELA LIN: Welcome to our
third episode of Women
Techmakers Give Back with
Codecademy's Sasha Laundy.
My name's Angela Lin,
and I work on the
YouTube Education Team.
I work with partners like TED,
Khan Academy, and edX to
ensure that anybody can learn
anything through YouTube.
Prior to Google, I worked
in entertainment.
I started my career
off at NBC.
If any of you have watched "30
Rock", you can think about
Kenneth the Page.
I was a page at NBC.
Google's not just about
work, work, work.
I also love to dance and try out
all the good eats around
San Francisco.
With that, I'll hand it to my
co-host Bridgette Sexton.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Thank you.
I'm Bridgette Sexton.
I'm on the Google for
Entrepreneurs Team.
My team focuses on how Google
can foster entrepreneurship
around the world.
We do this through a number of
things, partnerships with
groups like Startup Weekend, our
own programs, where we do
educational outreach and
actually help try to figure
out where entrepreneurs can fill
some white spaces and do
awesome things on the
web and mobile.
And we also look at our
products, how our products can
actually help entrepreneurs
grow their business.
Before this, I actually worked
on the Google Africa Team for
two years, based out of Ghana
and some out of Kenya as well.
[INAUDIBLE]
Google [? four ?]
[? five ?].
Before that, I just enjoyed
a lot of traveling.
And I also do some things out
of work, running, mainly,
running to work, biking to work,
and a lot of cooking.
But I have been fortunate to
just be surrounded by awesome
people here and impressive
women.
Today, we're actually
joined by one of
those impressive women.
Sasha Laundy, who was the fourth
employee at Codecademy.
And Sasha, would you mind
introducing yourself?
SASHA LAUNDY: Sure.
I'm really excited
to be here today.
This is a really cool series
that you guys are doing.
And I'm really honored
to be invited.
I currently work at Codecademy
in New York.
And I was the fourth
employee there.
We've doubled in size since I
started back in February.
And before that, I lived in San
Francisco and enjoyed all
the good eats around
San Francisco.
And I worked at Twilio, which
is a telephony API based in
downtown San Francisco.
Before that, I was developer
intern at this really tiny
gaming startup, pre-funding,
a very different
experience than Twilio.
Before that, I was a high
school teacher.
I taught physics and
neuroscience at high schools
in Connecticut and
San Francisco.
And so I did a big switch into
tech, while I was here.
It sort of was in the water
in San Francisco, I think.
And I'd be happy to talk
about all that today.
So I'm looking forward
to chatting.
ANGELA LIN: Well, you have
a fascinating background.
And we will get into it.
But first of all, why don't you
tell us a little bit about
Codecademy.
What types of coding
lessons do you use?
I spent some time on
the site, actually.
Admittedly got a little bit
hooked, myself, with one of
the courses.
I think that's one of the
things you mean to do.
SASHA LAUNDY: Yeah.
ANGELA LIN: So tell us a little
bit about your target
market and what you
guys are up to.
SASHA LAUNDY: Sure.
Absolutely.
If you've taken a look at our
website-- now might be a good
time to do that--
we offer interactive programming
lessons in HTML,
CSS, JavaScript, Python,
and Ruby.
And our aim is to get people
hooked on programming.
I think it's really important
that programming is seen as
something that's interesting
and can solve real problems
for people.
Because otherwise, young
people won't get
interested in it.
And we've got a big shortage
in developers right now.
So with our interactive lessons,
you're able to--
we don't make you do any
installation or downloads or
configuration, which can take a
really long time and really
isn't very fun.
The fun part is the coding.
So we let you get started
on that right away.
So there's a console on the
front page of our website that
asks you to type in your name.
And you start using strings
right away.
So you just get going coding.
And we make sure that the
lessons on our site are
interactive, so you can
actually learn by
doing, learn by coding.
Instead of having to pick up
a book and read hundreds of
pages, you can just get
started right away.
We also make sure that the
projects we have people doing
are really practical.
So instead of doing sort of an
esoteric math problem-- and
don't get me wrong, I
love math problems,
definitely love math.
But not everyone does.
And so we make sure that the
projects that people do are
really practical.
And so they feel like they could
pick this up and use it
in whatever job they have to
become more effective and
maybe do things faster
or more powerfully
than they could before.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
That's awesome.
How many users do you
guys have currently?
SASHA LAUNDY: We have
millions of users.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
That's awesome.
And how has the teaching of code
evolved over time, from
10 years ago, 20 years
ago, to what you guys
are teaching today?
And how are you seeing that
encouraging more?
SASHA LAUNDY: That's
a great question.
I wasn't learning programming
20 years ago.
But we have this rise of
interpreted languages that
abstract away some of the really
difficult parts about
programming, like memory
management
and things like that.
And so there are languages like
Python, which are great
to learn programming with
because They get rid of a lot
of the syntax that can really
trip up beginners and help
them really focus
on the concepts.
We're also able to put these
lessons online, which we
weren't able to do before.
But now we've got this pretty
massive web application that
lets you emulate all
these programming
languages in the browser.
We can host these sorts of
lessons online in a way that
we couldn't do 10
or 20 years ago.
So the advances in technology
and the internet are making it
a lot easier to teach
people in new ways.
So instead of the book and then
computer combination,
we've merged the two.
So the instruction and the
actual practice and learning
happen in the same console.
ANGELA LIN: So it seems like you
have a really innovative
course creator, where, like
you're saying, anybody can
actually teach a course and
put a course together.
Tell us a little bit more about
that and if you have a
favorite course that you've
created, that
we should be taking.
SASHA LAUNDY: Sure.
As you say, we've got a
course creator tool.
So anyone out there who's
interested in teaching the
world how to code can pick it
up and create a lesson that
looks just like the ones that
we have on our site.
And we've got this system
to help you.
We've got feedback at every
step of the way.
And we've got a few thousand
beta testers who are like
champing at the bit to get
access to the newest courses
and test out those courses and
get the bugs out before they
launch to the mainstream.
So we help you, basically,
learn this new format.
And there are some really
talented people who are great
at programming, great at
explaining, and this lets them
reach a huge audience.
Because we've got users in more
than 100 countries, and a
huge range of people
taking our lessons.
So I'd love to see what you'd
come up with there.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: I saw you guys
were offering kits for
after-school classes now.
How is that going?
SASHA LAUNDY: It's going
really well.
And let me tell you a little
bit about why we did that,
because I think it's important
to understand that.
Particularly for the sorts of
people who are watching this,
it's important to understand
what's happening with the
kids, especially in
the US right now.
We've actually seen a decline
in the number of computer
science courses, both AP level
and entry level that are
offered in the US.
And teachers are less and less
prepared to teach those
classes which is a problem,
because the internet is not
going away any time soon.
Technology is here to stay.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: We hope not.
We hope the internet is not
going away any time soon.
SASHA LAUNDY: And Google is
doing a great job in helping
it become here to stay and
keeping it useful and huge and
interesting.
So technology's not
going away.
And it's becoming increasingly
important that people
understand how technology works
when they use it-- that
they're not just consuming the
technology, but they have some
understanding of how
it was made.
And this is impacting field
after field after field.
You've seen what's happened
to the music industry in
the last few years.
It's going to revolutionize
pretty much every industry
that we have.
And so to become relevant and
valuable in this modern
society, you have to understand
technology and
really understand how things
are put together.
Because if you don't, it's very
easy for people who have
that power and have that
understanding to take
advantage of you and get ahead
in a way that you can't.
So schools.
Estonia.
Have you heard of this
Estonia news?
It's pretty interesting.
Estonia recently announced that
they're going to teach
every first grader
how to program.
Every first grader is going to
know how to program computers,
which is really interesting.
So Estonia is figuring
this out.
And they're like, OK, we have
to get ahead of this trend.
We have to prepare our students
for this modern
world, this brave new world.
And they're taking the
appropriate steps.
But the US is actually cutting
computer science classes.
So we've talked to a lot of
passionate teachers who
understand that this is a
problem, and they know they
need to prepare their
students.
And so we, basically, instead of
having them wait a year to
get trained and maybe wait
another year for their school
district to add in the computer
science classes, what
we've done is we made
a computer science
kit club in a box.
So they can pick this up.
They have all the lessons,
all the curriculum.
We even made like photocopyable
posters, with
cute robots on them.
So they photocopy them and put
them around their school
announcing their club.
Some stickers, because everyone
loves stickers.
And we've made this free for
anyone who signed up.
And we put it up on the web.
We didn't really know how many
people would be interested.
We made 250 kits and
hoped for the best.
I think we had 2,000 schools
sign up in the first month and
a half, which blew us away.
So there's clearly a ton
of demand for this.
And this isn't just in the US.
It's all over the
world as well.
But with these kits, teachers
can pick this up, get started
today, even if they don't know
how to program, which is
crucial, because since the
students get feedback on our
website, they don't need to know
how to program, because
they don't need to be grading
kids homework or
anything like that.
All of the backup support they
need is in the forums or in
the tool itself.
And it's just a really
useful tool.
So we've been hearing lots of
stories and getting cute
pictures from teachers who are
using this to teach kids how
to program.
A lot of really adorable games
have been emailed into us.
Even a few programming jokes,
which always makes our day.
And so we can't wait to see what
people do with it in the
spring semester.
ANGELA LIN: Are you thinking
about doing some sort of
hackathon to encourage these
students to compete, maybe,
internationally?
SASHA LAUNDY: That's
a great idea.
We haven't set that up yet.
But we've been supporting a few
people who are interested
in putting together hackathons
that are
more focused on beginners.
So they're starting to see
hackathons, instead of a
competition, where you go and
you already have skills, as a
way of acquiring those skills
and meeting new people and
learning new things.
And so it's interesting seeing
how the definition of a
hackathon is being broadened.
And we're able to support people
in that, because we
have these lessons that people
can use and teach their folks
in the hackathons
how to program.
ANGELA LIN: That's
really neat.
SASHA LAUNDY: Thanks.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: How have you
seen the kids who go through
this program, and also other
people in your courseware use
that and apply it in their own
lives and create technologies?
SASHA LAUNDY: That's
a great question.
We've seen a few different
things.
We've seen people who actually
make the switch from some
other career to programmer.
So they become professional
developers,
which is really cool.
They start with us and
generally add on more
information.
Because, right now, our
curriculum is really focused
on beginners.
And we've also seen people pick
this up and add skills to
their own skill set in their
own field, without becoming
professional developers.
There have been a few groups
that are particularly
interested in this.
Librarians are very much ahead
of the curve there.
Journalists and scientists are
also some other groups that
we'd seen form their own study
groups and apply their
learning to their own fields.
And there are also two
individuals, two
stories I can tell you.
One is this guy who took our
JavaScript lessons and managed
to put together an app
that's a workout app.
It picks a random
workout for you.
He based it on our dice game
lesson, which is early in our
JavaScript track.
And he put on the app store and
got 100,000 downloads in
the first few weeks it was up,
which was pretty cool.
So technology lets you reach
more people than you ever
could before.
It let's you reach people who
aren't near you, aren't in
your field.
And so that's another reason
why it's so important to
understand technology and be
able to create it, not just
consume it.
And one other story, which is
this woman named Martha who is
an 18-year-old in Kenya.
And she got an internship and
managed to get a hold of a
laptop and the internet
for the first time.
And she found our
lessons and got
hooked on the Ruby lessons.
So she quit her internship,
saved up enough to buy a
laptop, and is now working as
a Ruby on Rails apprentice
developer in Kenya.
And so she's been helping us
out with, actually, some of
our code on the site, which
is pretty cool.
So we hope to hear many more
stories like that.
And if you've got one, please
share it with us.
We'd love to hear it.
ANGELA LIN: So right now, I'm
just curious, the lessons are
very interactive.
And it's basically more
focused on text.
And I have to ask the YouTube
question, because I'm asking
from YouTube point of view.
Are you guys thinking about
incorporating video, at any
point, into the product?
SASHA LAUNDY: We
would love to.
I think there's a
role for video.
Just watching videos,
I think, is a step
in the right direction.
But combining it with video plus
being able to interact
with the material could
be really cool.
So let's talk about
that afterwards.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: And also
besides having courses on the
web technologies, which is
awesome, do you have any plans
of moving more towards having
some mobile programming
classes, like potentially
Android?
SASHA LAUNDY: Android.
We would love to.
And to do Android, we'd
need Java, right?
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Yes.
SASHA LAUNDY: We
would love to.
The tricky part about putting
Java in the web is that it's
compiled language, right?
So that adds some technical
hurdles for us, in terms of
implementing it.
But we would love to.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: We had an
emulator at one point.
We still do.
So maybe that's a potential way
that you could write it.
SASHA LAUNDY: OK, let's talk
about this [INAUDIBLE].
It's certainly very requested.
Lots of people are writing
and asking for Java
and asking for Android.
ANGELA LIN: So Sasha,
you gave us a
brief bio in the beginning.
You sound like you have a really
interesting background.
Tell us a little bit more about
what got you into tech.
Maybe even when you
were a teacher--
are there things that
Codecademy's enabling now that
you feel like, if only I had
this tool when I was teaching?
SASHA LAUNDY: That's
a great question.
Yeah, I think my story is a
good example of why I'm so
passionate about what Codecademy
is doing and why I
made the leap to move to New
York and work for this company
when it was so tiny.
Someone, I still, to this day,
don't know who, added
programming to my sophomore
year of high
school course schedule.
And I was like, OK, why not.
I don't know what this C++ is.
But I took this class.
It was in C++.
And I really enjoyed
writing programs.
I got really into it.
It was like solving a puzzle.
But the projects we did
were so boring.
It was like formatting
a receipt from
your restaurant bill--
that I was just like, why would
I do this when I could
do physics?
And so I went off and I studied
physics and I ended up
majoring in physics at
Swarthmore College.
And that was great.
But as I got to know people
who were in the computer
science program there-- and
there's a great computer
science program there--
I got to see that they were
doing really interesting work
and solving really interesting
problems.
And I took a computer vision
class, where we had to try to
identify faces, just based on
the pixels, and write an
algorithm that found
your eyes.
That's one project we did.
And it was only at that point
that I figured out cool
programming was.
And so I really wish that I'd
had a much more engaging
experience that got me hooked
much younger, because I would
be much farther along, in terms
of my own programming
skills, than I am now if I had
gotten started earlier.
So I'm really excited to get
lots of the new generation of
kids hooked on programming
really young.
And so, yeah, that's why I think
it's so important to
make it fun at first.
It doesn't have to be fun
the whole time, right?
There are frustrating
bits of it.
But it's really important that
people's first impression of
programming is practical,
interesting, and engaging.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: You probably
never thought you'd be where
you are, right now, today.
SASHA LAUNDY: Nope.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: It's a pretty
awesome transition from
being a teacher into what
you're doing now.
We love scale at Google, so the
idea of scaling education.
Especially YouTube is
huge into that.
And I think that we look at
great content as being a key.
How do you guys keep
your content fresh?
How do you know what
to teach next?
Or are you really focused
on the basics?
SASHA LAUNDY: That's
a great question.
And we're doing a combination of
refreshing and focusing on
the basics.
When you get started, you have
to understand a certain number
of building blocks,
conceptually, in programming
to be able to build anything,
for loops, if...else
statements.
Variables are a really tricky
concept for beginners.
So we need people to learn some
of the basics before they
can do interesting stuff.
So right now, we're
focusing on that.
But we're gradually expanding
it as well.
So there are more and more--
we launched projects this past
week, so you can pick up what
you've learned and build
something cool with it.
Sorry, tell me the second part
of your question again?
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Just staying
fresh, like staying up to
date, it's such a challenge.
SASHA LAUNDY: Thank you.
We do a lot of testing to make
sure that our lessons are
working for people.
So we have a lot of metrics.
We gather a lot of feedback.
We make sure to refresh the
courses, so that they're as
high quality as possible, and
so that people stick around
and learn as long as possible.
So we're doing a combination
of adding to our curriculum
and refreshing what we
already have as well.
ANGELA LIN: When a new course
is created, is the vetting
done by the beta testers that
you were talking about?
Or is there someone on the
team that actually goes
through first?
SASHA LAUNDY: A combination.
So when you pick up the course
creator tool, and you create a
course, we offer feedback
at a few stages.
Someone from Codecademy
currently looks at your course
and gives you feedback on
it for the first stage.
And then once it's moved over
to beta testers, we've got
thousands of beta testers who
have signed up to test the
latest courses and give
some feedback on it.
And so they do a great job of
finding any of those rough
spots, things that might not be
super clearly explained, or
any bugs in the submission
correctness test.
And they find those and expose
those, before the course goes
out to everyone else, which
is super helpful.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: We actually
have a question, on our Dory
here, for what is the best
web languages to learn.
This is from New Jersey.
SASHA LAUNDY: I think I might
know who that is.
It might be one of
our beta testers.
What is the best language?
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Yes.
What are the best languages
to learn.
So this guy seems like
he's just getting
started with [? DOM ?].
Where should he start?
SASHA LAUNDY: That's
a great question.
And I think that's one place--
I know, when I was starting, I
got totally overwhelmed by the
number of things.
I was like, I have to learn HTML
and CSS and Python and
Django and Ruby and Rails.
And like, oh, why not throw in
some [? Scene, ?] because
that'll teach you memory
management and fundamentals,
all the stuff I missed
because I wasn't a
computer science major.
And I think it's really easy
to get overwhelmed.
But picking one thing that's a
good fit for what you want to
do and just learning that
and like getting to
it, have a good time.
It doesn't particularly matter
what you pick up, as long as
you pick it up and stay with
it until you learn the
fundamentals.
And when in doubt, I'm
a Python girl.
Python's a great all purpose
programming language.
It's pretty easy to pick up.
It teaches you the same concepts
that you'll need for
other languages.
So, when it doubt, Python.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: And
Google loves Python.
We love Python.
ANGELA LIN: I guess related to
the first question, we also
have one around the
best sequencing.
So you wee talking about which
ones-- and Python.
There's definitely tracks
that you can go down.
Is there a recommended
sequence of tracks?
SASHA LAUNDY: Sure.
You're referring to tracks
on our site?
ANGELA LIN: Mm hm.
SASHA LAUNDY: Yeah.
So if you take a look at our
site, we've got tracks that
guide you through.
And that's another thing we
do, because we found that
beginners get super
overwhelmed.
And they don't know
where to start.
And so we've created these
tracks that make a really
linear path, just to
get them started.
And we find that, once people go
through those tracks, they
can then understand the choices
they're making much
better and can make better
choices and feel less
overwhelmed by the choices
that they have.
But in terms of going through
the tracks, if you're a
complete beginner, and you're a
little scared, that's fine.
You're not alone.
Trust me.
We get emails from those
people all the time.
But I recommend starting with
what we call the web track,
which is HTML and CSS.
You'll make a first web page.
It's not technically
programming.
Lots of people would say, hey,
that's not programming.
But it does get you familiar
with a tool.
It gets you understanding that
the thing you write and the
final product are two
different things.
And you can make a
cool web page.
And then you can learn
JavaScript, which lets you
make that web page interactive
and do cool stuff.
ANGELA LIN: I'm writing
that down.
SASHA LAUNDY: So web track
first if you're nervous.
If you've done some programming
or already made
websites before, I'd recommend
starting with Python, Ruby, or
JavaScript.
Oh, and we have a new jQuery
track, which is really cool.
Because jQuery is a library
of JavaScript.
So there's all this pre-written
code, all over the
internet, that you can use.
So you don't have to write as
much, but you can do really
impressive stuff, like fade in,
fade out, like sliding,
accordion web pages and
stuff like that.
So that's actually a pretty
fun and flashy way to get
started if you want to
impress your friends.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: What are some
of the favorite things
that you've built using
your skills?
Especially transitioning from
neuroscience into coding,
probably bringing some of that
background with you.
But even just some fun, flashy
website, what are the things
that you've created that you
are proud of, that you've
enjoyed, that have been fun?
SASHA LAUNDY: And I haven't
managed to work my
neuroscience skills
into this yet.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: I was
imagining some digital
encyclopedia of awesome
neuroscience--
SASHA LAUNDY: Ah, I'd
love to do that.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: --tips.
SASHA LAUNDY: Unfortunately, I
haven't figured out how to do
that yet, how to combine
the two yet.
But I'll think about it.
I think one thing that having
technical skills and knowing
how to program has really
helped me do a lot of
different things in all these
different roles I've had in
the tech world.
Here at Codecademy, it helps
me understand how hard
programming languages are both
to implement, for our
engineering team, and for
how hard it is for
people to learn them.
Because I've learned enough of
them to understand where the
stumbling blocks are and what
might be an appropriate choice
for a beginner.
And it also allows
me to fix things.
We're a really small team.
We're 12 people now.
And so when there's a bug that's
maybe noncritical but
interfering with people's
learning, I can pick it up and
fix it in our code base and push
a fix that our engineers
can deploy.
So it saves them some time, gets
more done for our users,
and is a hugely useful skill.
I'd highly recommend learning
how to program, especially if
you're interested in
the tech world.
ANGELA LIN: Tell us
a little bit--
you founded Women
Who Code, right?
SASHA LAUNDY: Yeah.
ANGELA LIN: Tell us a little
bit about that.
SASHA LAUNDY: Sure.
So when I was living in San
Francisco, and I was making
the switch over and learning
as much programming as
possible, I found that it's
somewhat challenging to be a
woman in the tech community,
especially in the technical
community, because there's
so few women there.
And sometimes people would
assume I was a recruiter at
events or what have you.
And so I really just wanted a
place to be where I could talk
to other technical women, get
to know them, and just talk
about code.
And so I put this meetup
on the calendar.
This was, I think,
August, 2010--
2011.
Sorry, blanking on the date--
just over a year ago.
And I was like, man, I hope 10
people show up and code with
me, because I'm going to
feel really silly if
no one shows up.
And 100 people signed up
for the first event.
So I was blown away
by the interest.
Basically, the organization
hosts hack-nights and tech
talks for women in program.
They can be beginners or
professional developers, but
we come and sit in the same
room and share what we're
working on and help each other
and get to know each other.
And so seeing some of the
connections that have come out
of that have been really cool.
People have gotten hired.
They've found mentors
and mentees.
They've found friends.
I know I hired someone
I met through that.
So that's pretty cool.
And it's really taken off.
There are chapters starting up
in Denver, Arkansas, LA, as
well as, maybe, one in Canada,
coming soon, to be TBD.
And there's a Silicon Valley
branch as well.
So it's nearby if you guys
want to check it out.
And we recently hit 2,000 women,
which is pretty cool,
for something that's spreading
by word of mouth on Twitter
and Meetup.
And it's really providing a safe
space for women who want
to meet other women and know
that they're out there.
ANGELA LIN: And what about
inspiring young women who may
not be in the professional world
yet, but who aspire to--
or you want to get them
interested in coding and the
tech world?
SASHA LAUNDY: It's really
important, because, again, to
be honest, I think programming,
as a profession,
as a field, as a passion, has
a huge marketing problem.
It's seen as something that's
only for really geeky white
guys in a basement
like typing away.
But it's so much more broad
and interesting than that.
And I think it's really
important to get young people
interested, especially young
women, just because, for some
reason, we're not telling
the right story
to them at the moment.
And there are a lot of
organizations that are
interested in doing that.
Women Who Code is focused on
professional developers.
But there are all
sorts of camps.
There's one called Black Girls
Code that runs workshops.
There's Girls Who Code
out in New York.
There are a ton of ways
to get involved.
So if you're interested in
teaching high school kids,
even just call up your local
school and be like, hi, I'm a
professional developer.
Is there a computer science
teacher who would be
interested in like maybe me
coming to speak one day or
helping out with programming
classes?
There are tons of people who
could use your expertise, so
just get in touch.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
That's awesome.
Well, speaking of this, do you
have any role models yourself
that have kept you going in
life, like people that you
aspire to be like or even
mentors along the way that
have helped you?
SASHA LAUNDY: Yeah,
absolutely.
And so many people who have
inspired me and helped me.
I was thinking about this
question the other day.
And I was remembering my
Halloween costume when I was
eight years old.
I handmade my own costume.
I was Athena.
I was really into mythology.
I went through a mythology
phase.
ANGELA LIN: I think everyone
goes through that phase.
SASHA LAUNDY: Yeah.
There's this D'Aulaires'
book with the
colored pencil drawings.
It's beautiful.
I apparently identified with
Athena enough to dress up as
her for Halloween.
And she's the Greek goddess
of knowledge.
And she's a bit of a warrior.
So that was, I think, a good
role model for little Sasha
back in the day.
But since then, there have been
so many professionals--
I wanted to be a scientist
for a really long time--
and people in tech who've
built amazing
things out of thin air.
That's the thing I love most
about this community and
startups is that you take a
computer and a command line,
and you build this amazing
product that helps change
people's lives.
So I'm just really excited to
be part of this community.
And maybe some other people will
follow me down this road.
ANGELA LIN: What's something
that you have on the horizon
that you want to build?
Maybe you don't have all of the
skills yet to build it, or
it's just the time
or the energy.
What's something that you've
always wanted to do?
SASHA LAUNDY: So I have this
list on my computer of the
things I should program.
And it's really long.
Some of them are silly ones.
I've got some chat bots for--
we have this chat
program that we use.
And you can write little
programs in it.
And some of them are
silly like that.
Some of them are major features
on our website.
And some are smaller tweaks.
But knowing how to program
changes the way
you look at the world.
So that when you know what you
can do with a skill set, you
start seeing things to
build everywhere.
It's like goggles, like
Google Glass.
And all of a sudden, you can see
all these things that you
can change.
So I have a very long list.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
That's awesome.
We another question from an
audience member, which is, do
you have a favorite
code editor?
And he says he's also a beta
tester for you guys.
SASHA LAUNDY: Cool.
That's awesome.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: He's a fan.
SASHA LAUNDY: Thanks
for the question.
I really like Sublime Text 2.
It's really beautiful.
It's a program that you can
open and start using right
away, so it's got a very low
barrier to entry, highly
recommended.
I've also been learning Vim
recently, which I stopped--
this is very nerdy--
learning Vim just because
the keyboard shortcuts--
you have to use a lot of
keyboard shortcuts to use it.
And I switched to the Dvorak
keyboard, when I was bored one
summer in college, and I've
never switched back.
So it's really not
optimized for me.
But now, I'm just
sort of like--
it lets you do so many things
so much faster that I'm
picking it up anyway.
So it depends on how much time
you want to spend learning
your text editor.
If you don't, Sublime Text 2.
If you want to invest
the time, Vim.
ANGELA LIN: So you were talking
about, you switched
over to the-- you
were just bored?
SASHA LAUNDY: Yeah.
In college, you've got
time in the summers.
And, apparently, I wanted
to type faster.
And so I switched to Dvorak.
And here I am, too lazy
to switch back.
ANGELA LIN: Can you buy a
laptop with a Dvorak?
SASHA LAUNDY: You could.
I just touch type.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
That's great.
SASHA LAUNDY: Yeah,
very nerdy.
ANGELA LIN: Let's see,
another question.
By the way, you guys should
send in questions, because
we're actively looking
at the Dory.
I'm in high school in
a data structures
course that uses Java.
What languages should I learn
after Java, and what are
recommended future routes?
From John in New York.
SASHA LAUNDY: That's
a great question.
And I think it really depends
on what your goals are.
If you want to learn the
fundamentals of computer
science, Java is
a great start.
There's some others that are
particularly interesting.
You could check out a
functional language.
I know Haskell is really
trendy in the hacker
community right now.
If you're interested in more
going to web programming,
there are all these interpretive
languages that
you can learn.
So it really depends on
what your goals are.
Sorry I can't give a more
specific answer than that.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: I actually
would like to go back a little
bit to the schools and talk
about, what do you think are
some of the things that
teachers, educators, people
can do to encourage more kids
to take that first leap into
programming?
Because I know it's a global
concern that we need more
programmers and developers,
both from a professional
level, but even just sort of
that knowledge base of people
understanding how code words,
how their computer works, and
demystifying technology
in that sense.
SASHA LAUNDY: Yeah, I think
that's a great question.
How do we get more people
interested?
I think it's important to see
how powerful it is and what
you can do with a little
bit of knowledge.
Because there are only a small
subset of people that like
learning programming for its
own sake and think it's
inherently interesting.
For the vast majority of people,
they're interested in
what you can do with it.
So showing people what they can
do and showing people role
models that look like them are
both really important.
ANGELA LIN: And related to
that education question,
there's so much happening in the
ed tech space in general
right now, how do you
view Codecademy in
that broader landscape?
And have you made connections
with other people who have
that same mission to help
educate students
all over the world?
SASHA LAUNDY: Absolutely.
There are a lot of people
who are interested in
this space right now.
And there are a lot of people
who are taking different
approaches, a lot of new
companies who are taking
different approaches to
get to the same goal.
There are some people who
are more video based.
There are some that are starting
up in-person classes
or this hybrid model, where you
do some stuff in-person,
some stuff online.
And then there's the approach
we're taking with an
interactive console.
So it's really interesting to
see which methods will be most
effective for which people.
So I'm really curious to see how
the next few years go in
this space.
Because there's so much energy
and excitement and venture
funding there right now, which
is a sign of where people's
attention is.
ANGELA LIN: I think you hit
on a really good point.
Different people learn
differently.
And so how do you address that
at Codecademy, in terms of
learning styles.
Some people are more visual,
other are more aural.
SASHA LAUNDY: I think the
research shows that the
learning style, in terms of
audio or visual, actually
doesn't make a huge
difference.
Because every person uses all
those styles at different
points and different times.
So I think it's really a
question of matching the skill
that you're learning to the
method in which you're
learning it.
I wouldn't try to teach someone
to juggle by video on
the internet.
That's not going to
work-- or like
cartwheel or dance or whatever.
That's really challenging,
because the medium
doesn't fit the topic.
But for programming, you
actually learn by doing
programming.
You don't learn by reading.
If you think about it, you want
to learn how to write
programs, so you read a book.
That doesn't make sense.
But if you want to learn how to
program, you should program.
And this gets you as close as
I've seen to melding the two.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Now,
I think we have one
more question here.
Do you have any plans for
PHP or Java courses?
But I think you already
have them.
SASHA LAUNDY: We don't yet.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
Oh, you don't.
SASHA LAUNDY: But those are
definitely some of the most
requested languages.
People really want
to learn PHP.
They really want
to learn Java.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Do you
have a date coming out?
SASHA LAUNDY: I don't have a
specific date, but we are
working on it.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Do you
want to launch it,
right here, right now?
SASHA LAUNDY: Yeah,
just a second.
ANGELA LIN: Put that on your
list of things to build.
SASHA LAUNDY: It's on there.
Trust me.
I'm sorry we don't
have it yet.
We will soon.
ANGELA LIN: Anything else that
you would like to share with
the audience at large.
SASHA LAUNDY: I think
there's a lot of the
conversation about--
and I'm saying this as a former
teacher, because I see
both sides of this argument.
There are a lot of people who
say that, because all this
content is shifting to the web,
you can learn anything
you want in these MOOCs and
these video sites and on
Codecademy and all that, that
teachers, as a profession, are
going to be replaced, sort of
become out of date, or shift
to being computerized
in some way.
And I think that's really,
fundamentally,
misunderstanding what
teaching is.
Teachers are a lot more than
content delivery robots.
They also get to know you and
push you when you're stuck and
reward you and coach you and
help you and cheer for you
when you're succeeding.
And they are able to
contextualize all those
generic resources that people
have-- the textbooks, the
video sites, whatever.
They're able to contextualize
those and put them in a form
that works for the individual
learner.
And that's something that
computers are never really
going to get that good at.
The content delivery part is
actually a great help to
teachers, in that they no longer
have to do that as part
of their jobs.
They're able to be freed up to
spend more time, one-on-one,
with students, which is
really their strength.
I would love to see teachers
tell that story and that
narrative about this change,
so that they can gracefully
make that leap into
the next stages.
Because again, this technology
isn't going away.
It's here to stay.
And it's going to change
and get better.
But teachers definitely have
a place in this world.
And I think it's a really
interesting one.
ANGELA LIN: Before we let you
go, we have another question
from the Dory, from Jim,
in North Carolina.
I'm currently making a career
change after being a
journalist for 10 years.
As someone who made the
transition smoothly, what kind
of advice would you give.
SASHA LAUNDY: That's
a great question.
The transition was super
interesting.
I'd love to know actually what
he's transitioning to.
Did he mention that?
ANGELA LIN: He did not say.
Jim, if you type in your answer
really quickly, maybe
we can get to it.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Sounds like
a transition into at least
something in the tech space.
SASHA LAUNDY: And I can tell
you, roughly, what I did to
make this transition.
A year before-- because in
teaching you have to give four
months notice when you
change fields, which
is a long lead time.
So a year before I made the
switch, I started going to
meetups around--
I had the advantage of being in
the Bay Area, which has a
different meetup every night,
on whatever you want.
There's people here doing it.
And so I got to know people
in the industry.
And I learned more about the
field to make sure I wasn't
crazy and that I would have
something to contribute.
And one really important thing
that I did is I built things,
and I showed them,
so that people
knew that I was serious.
I built programs and
showed them.
I worked for free for a startup
for a while, building
their product alongside
the CTO.
I started Women Who Code.
People were very impressed by
that, because it's taken off
so quickly.
I built things to show
that I was serious.
And they were things that were
free and weren't like years in
the making, but they were
showing that I was thinking
about the field in
the right way.
So ask lots of questions, listen
hard, and build cool
things, and take
it from there.
MALE SPEAKER: Sasha, there was
one question on YouTube that
goes back to teaching.
How can teachers who are in
the classroom now leverage
Codecademy with their
students?
SASHA LAUNDY: That's also
a great question.
I think one thing that the
lessons really free teachers
up to do is to, again, spend
that one-on-one time with the
kids who need it.
So because the content and
because a lot of the feedback
is actually in the tool, and
teachers don't need to supply
that themselves, they can
spend a lot more time
one-on-one with individual kids
who might be struggling,
or kids who finish our
curriculum in five minutes and
need more stuff to do, which
has definitely happened.
So one model that a lot of
teachers are exploring right
now is the flipped classroom
where they do their reading--
and what they used to do in
class, the sort of knowledge
absorption step of read the
thing, get it into your brain.
They do that at home.
And when they come in, they work
on homework, they work on
problems, they write
little programs.
And that's when the teacher's
input is actually most useful.
So having this content on the
internet, whenever, available
from wherever you want
is great because
they can do it home.
And then they can use the
classroom time more
effectively.
So that's one thing we've
been hearing a lot
of good things about.
And we'd love to hear more
about how it's working.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Awesome.
Last good question.
Besides starting amazing
organizations and working t a
world class institution,
what do you do for fun?
What do you do outside
of work?
SASHA LAUNDY: What
do I do for fun?
That's a funny question.
I've been very focused on
Codecademy recently.
But I'm pretty athletic.
We're actually a really
athletic office.
By far the most athletic tech
company I've ever seen.
We all go for runs, sometimes
together, and go to the gym.
When I lived in San Francisco,
I did a lot of cycling.
That's a little bit harder to
do in New York, because the
roads are little more
interesting.
But I really like sports.
I love science.
I miss it a lot.
I like writing.
And I love cooking.
Don't get to do it
a lot anymore.
It's really hard to
do in New York.
And I actually like knitting.
And I see a lot of parallels
between knitting and
programming.
So I can make pretty much
anything you want.
It's a really esoteric skill.
Helps keep my hands busy.
And I have lots of
scarves now.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON:
Yeah, I actually
started knitting in college.
I ran track in college.
And I used to knit on the bus,
because there was nothing else
I could do.
And it was hours and hours
and hours of it.
SASHA LAUNDY: A good
use for it.
That's cool.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Well, thank
you so much for joining us.
We really appreciate you
taking the time.
This has been a really
fun series.
I think, globally, we've
realized how many amazing,
impressive women there
are out there.
Maybe there isn't a chance for
them to get exposed as often
as they should be.
And you're doing a great job
bringing that to light through
Women Who Code.
So thank you so much.
SASHA LAUNDY: Thanks
for having me.
This was a really cool series.
And I can't wait to see
what other great
people you have on here.
Thank you for having me.
ANGELA LIN: Thanks
for being here.
BRIDGETTE SEXTON: Viewers,
thank you for joining us.
We have another session
tomorrow, with Kim Pelosi.
And it'll be here at 2:30.
So please, come back
and join us again.
Thank you.